alexis boulin néanmoins vous qu'est ce
que vous retenez de cette prise de
parole des manuels ce macron ce soir est
ce qu'il a répondu aux interrogations
des français sont pas du tout il a
simplement mis les français dans une
position de dépendance d'infantilisation
même s'il s'en défend
ce qu'on retient de cette allocution
c'est que visiblement le travail protège
du virus parce que en dehors du travail
tout est interdite le couvre feu mais
quelle est cette idée du couvre-feu à
part d'interdire aux gens d'avoir une
vie sociale d'interdire aux gens d'aller
et venir comme ils veulent c'est
incroyable nous vivons en france une
démocratie libérale en europe qui est
totalement guidés par le libéralisme et
là nous avons des dirigeants qui
décident de manière totalement mais mais
mais sans vote sans rien c'est à dire
qu'on est encore cadre de la démocratie
qu on est dans les deux lois d'exception
on est dans la danse est dans cette
guerre sanitaire qui leur permet de
pousser les lois d'exception et qui nous
interdit de nous déplacer librement
mais pourquoi nous devrions accepter ça
je suis citoyen français j'ai été outré
par ce que j'ai entendu ce soir par le
petit sourire narquois de monsieur macro
qui disait c'est difficile d'avoir 20
ans en 2020 mais je crois que c'est
difficile d'être citoyen français sous
cette présidence parce que depuis 2010 8
pas 2017 je pense qu'il ya eu un temps
où tout allait à peu près mais depuis la
crise des gilets jaunes
on a vu des débordements d'autoritarisme
un point tel qu'on n'avait jamais connu
en france et là ce soir on a un roi qui
décide unilatéralement de nous empêcher
d'aller et venir parce que soi-disant un
virus serait dangereux seulement à
partir de 21h mais rendez vous contes de
la folie qui est en train de s'imposer
sur nous de vrais devrions nous accepter
une chose pareille je pense pas je pense
que derrière ce soir le grand oublié de
l'interview c'était les chiffres combien
de personnes se soient en réanimation
combien de personnes ce soir sont mortes
quelle quelle était leur âge
quelles étaient leurs conditions de
comorbidité qui tue ce virus
quel est le danger réel pourquoi nous en
sommes là parce que derrière nous avons
des gens qui acceptent qu'ils vivent
dans la peur des médias qui ont joué
avec la peur ce n'est pas le cas de rt
frange les jours merci et un système qui
a permis à emmanuel macron d'étendre une
toile d'autoritarisme sur un pays
pourtant libre
je suis désolé ce virus n'a aucune
raison de nous empêcher de faire ce
qu'on veut après 21h n'a aucune raison
de faire fermer la porte à je sais pas
combien de milliers de restaurateurs de
patrons de boîte de nuit
le patron de bar ce virus n'est pas là
pour tuer l'économie or ce que nous dit
emmanuel macron c'est qu'il faut
travailler pour sauver l'économie mais
il y aura des secteurs sacrifiés et il y
aura des morts parce que c'est une
guerre et il y aura des morts mais
comment peut-on accepter une chose
pareille on a un président de la
république ce soir qui nous parle
et voilà ce qu'il nous dit simplement
qu'il va nous faire souffrir qu'il va
vous faire souffrir pour notre bien tout
simplement parce que le couvre-feu
c'est une bonne chose en ile de france
rendez vous compte en ile de france vous
avez des villages qui sont perdus au
milieu des champs c'est les pauvres gens
dans ces villages si jamais ils sortent
ils auront droit à 135 euros d'amendé
alors peut-être que parce qu'on est en
train de discuter du projet de loi de
finances 2010 21 et qu'on n'a pas le
droit de faire de nouveaux impôts
l'amande est devenu le nouvel impôt
amendes pour non port du masque amende
parce qu'on ne respectera pas ce
couvre-feu
comment voulez vous quand vous sortez du
boulot rentrez chez vous à 21h les
transports vont être bondé vous allez
faire en fait des miyako ville parce que
les gens vont être obligés d'aller dans
des tunnels dans les transports à la
même heure parce qu'à 21h c'est tout le
monde chez soi alors